[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARA ZASKE: Hello.
My name's Sara Zaske.
And I'm here to talk to
you about "Achtung Baby"
and how Germans raise their
kids for self-reliance.
I'm really happy to
be here at Google.
But before I start, I'd like
to ask you a few questions.
I know who I'm talking to.
So first of all, how many
of you here are parents?
And it's OK you're not.
Oh, a lot.
Good.
You're in the right place.
How many of you have school-aged
kids, so ages 6 to 12?
Oh, quite a few.
So let me ask you this.
If you have kids aged 6 to
12 or you had them older,
think back to that time.
How many of you let
them walk places
by themselves to the
friend's house, to the park--
I see my allies back there--
or to school?
So just a couple.
As you know, you're very
typical American parents.
The rest of you--
the dominant style
of American parenting
today is high on supervision.
And not just
physical supervision.
I don't know about you.
But I have this nifty
thing back in my home town
called power loop where
I can watch the grades
as they come in in real time.
Well, that's a lot
of supervision.
And we have the best
intentions, right?
We want our kids to be safe.
We want them to succeed.
But we exercise so
much control in trying
to make those two things happen
that we've actually become more
controlling than German parents,
which sounds like an odd thing
to say.
Because when we think of
Germans, what do we think?
Strict people, right?
Very exacting people,
rule following.
I had all of those ideas in my
head when I moved to Germany.
But very quickly, I
learned that what I thought
was not exactly correct.
When I first moved to Germany,
my daughter was 2 and 1/2.
And we lived there
for 6 and 1/2 years.
And one of the first
things I noticed
was how Germans interact or
don't interact with their kids
on the playground.
One story that I tell
often, because it
was so shocking to me, was
I was at the playground
with my young daughter.
She's was still
about two or three.
And another kid who
was eight or nine
had climbed on outside of
a playground structure.
And it was really high.
And he's dangling
there by one hand.
And there's a good 10 feet
below him to the sand.
And I stand up, and I
go, "achtung," which
means attention, watch out.
Where is this kid's mom?
I'm looking at all
the other adults
at the edge of the park drinking
coffee, not worried at all.
And by the time I
turn back, the kid
drops down, looks at me like
I'm crazy, and runs away.
And then I thought, huh,
there's something going on here
that I don't quite understand.
And I found myself having many
of those kinds of experiences
in Berlin, where I'm the
one yelling "achtung"
and running after
the kids or thinking
I've got to watch them
on every playground.
And I started to think,
why am I so afraid?
Or better yet, why are
the Germans not afraid?
So I'm not going
to talk too much
about what's wrong
with American parenting
because I'm sure we've
heard it all, right?
Some people call it
helicopter parenting.
Some people call
it overparenting.
I think the most precise
term that I've heard
is from psychologist Peter Gray.
And he calls it,
protective-directive parenting.
And I would add that I think
it's primarily based on fear.
We're afraid for our kids'
safety, so we protect.
And a lot of that protection
involves restricting.
You can't walk alone.
You can't play alone.
You can't do anything
that's vaguely dangerous.
The direction part comes in our
fear for their future success
or failure.
So we direct all
their academic grades.
We watch their grades
really closely.
And if they start
to flounder, we
get on the kid or we
get on the teacher
or we have a meeting
with the principal
and we make sure they fill
out their academic resume
with plenty of extracurricular
sports or violin
or learning a language.
And that style of parenting
doesn't leave a lot of room
for the kids to make
choices or mistakes.
And taken to its extreme,
some American parents
protect and direct
through adolescence
and into young adulthood.
And that doesn't leave
a lot of opportunity
for the kid to become
an independent adult.
But one place that they
don't do this is in Germany.
Oh, I forgot this.
Pardon me.
But for those of you who
are parents-- most of
you are parents here.
I don't think of raising
kids as a side issue.
This is something that is
important for all, all of us.
And it sounds cliche, but
children are literally
the future.
When we get older, they're
going to be the ones
running the economy,
making the decisions,
hopefully founding the
next innovative idea that
changes our lives.
And so with that
bigger perspective
in mind and your own
personal perspective,
I'd like you to consider
these two lists.
So which is more
important to you
for children to learn,
obedience or self-reliance,
if you had to choose
between the two?
Respect for elders
or independence?
Being well-behaved
or being considerate?
Good manners or curiosity?
I'll give you a moment
just to think about it.
And some of you may have
seen this list before.
It's not mine.
It's a list that
researchers use to determine
how authoritarian you are.
So if you chose
the first column--
obedience, respect
for elders-- if you
chose more of
those things you're
more authoritarian
in your worldview.
If you chose the second column--
self-reliance,
independence, curiosity--
you're less authoritarian.
Now, I'm going to
take a wild guess.
Because we're here
at Google in Seattle.
Most of you probably took
self-reliance, independence,
that call.
That's great.
And those are all
very American values.
However, if you parrot in that
dominant, directive-protective
style that I just
mentioned, you're
actually reinforcing
the first column.
Because in order
to do that, you're
asking for a lot of the
obedience from your kids,
a lot of respect for elders,
and good behavior instead
of their own initiative.
So as I said before,
the one place
they don't do this, this
first column, is Germany.
And while I had that
stereotype of Germans
as being the strict,
overbearing parents,
that's true in the 1940s.
Things have changed a lot
in Germany since then.
And in fact, World
War II prompted
a big reaction against
that kind of parenting
and really against
everything the Nazis did.
The generation that
came after them
who were growing up in
the 1960s really rebelling
against their parents.
I mean it was going on here too.
But the Germans
really had some things
to rebel against of course,
including how their parents
raised their kids.
So there was even an
anti-authoritarian movement.
And some people opened
up daycare centers that
had absolutely no rules at all.
And I've seen some videos
of those daycare centers.
And they're pretty wild.
And things have come
back a bit then.
German parents are much more
moderate than that extreme.
However, you would be
really hard-pressed to find
many German educators
or parents would
advocate for a strict,
controlling way of dealing
with kids.
And some evidence to that
fact is, around 2000, they
banned corporal
punishment, which means,
it is illegal to spank
your child in Germany.
And when you think
about it, that's perhaps
the most authoritarian
thing you can do to a child
is your physical power
over them to try to force
them to do what you want to do.
So while they may be
anti-authoritarian,
German society is anything
but a wild bunch of people
just running around in chaos.
So how do they do it?
How do they manage to
raise kids who are not only
independent, but responsible?
The good news is that
you do less, not more.
The bad news is that doing less
can be really, really hard.
Whenever I talk
to German parents
and say, how can you let
your kids walk to school
or take the subway
by themselves,
they say, I'm afraid.
I hate it.
But I have to.
Because if I'm always with them
and I'm always hovering over
them, they'll never have a
chance to learn independence.
So they don't just throw their
kids out there, give them
a subway ticket and say, find
your way or go find school.
They spend a lot of time
preparing their kids
to take on each new
step of responsibility.
And one example of this
is walking to school.
In first grade, I walked my
daughter to school every day
about 900 yards through
busy city streets of Berlin.
There is about 3.5
million people there.
And at the end of first grade,
they had a little course,
her teacher did,
on traffic safety.
And they showed her the [GERMAN]
outside the school, which
are like the crosswalks
and basically
the whole area
around the school.
And after that, I was
supposed to let her try
to walk to school on her own.
And I thought, hm, she's
seven, and I'm American.
We are not doing that.
And so ashamed to admit,
I walked her every day
through most of second
grade and part of third,
while all her other friends
were walking to school
by themselves.
And one day, she
finally said to me,
you know, mom, I can do this.
And I said, well, the traffic.
And there's these
seedy guys who hang out
in the corner in the afternoon.
And I don't like that.
And she said, mom, all my
friends do it and they're fine.
Now, I hate the "all
my friends" thing.
However, she did have a point.
While I was walking my
daughter to school every day,
her best friend was biking
from much further away.
And every day she would
cross a really busy street,
Frankfurter Allee.
And she still does, as I
know, and she has not yet
been hit by a car.
So there is some evidence there.
And then I did eventually let
my daughter go walk to school.
And when I did, it
was transformative,
not just for her, but for me.
For her, all of a
sudden, it was easier
to go to school in the morning.
She got herself up, got dressed,
made a snack, packed her back--
so proud.
Said goodbye to mom at the door.
And for me it was like,
oh, this is really my job.
I thought my job was to
make you completely safe
and to make sure
that you succeed.
But really my job
is to teach you how
to do things and then let go.
So the German method is
to prepare their kids--
instead of trying to
keep them 100% safe,
but to prepare them to
manage risk themselves.
Because if we really
admit it to ourselves,
there is no way that we can
make the world 100% safe
for our kids.
That's just not the
nature of the world.
The best thing that
we can do for them is
give them the skills they need
to manage risk on their own.
And one way Germans do
this from an early age
is through playgrounds.
There we go.
And not this playground.
This playground is in a
typical American playground.
Does it look familiar?
You could probably find
this in any city in America.
It's plastic.
It's short.
The slides are plastic,
so they're not very fast.
There is not a whole
lot of risk to be
had here, except for
maybe a three-year-old
or a four-year-old.
After that, it's not
even very interesting.
This is a more typical
German playground.
And I say typical.
But I have never seen one German
playground that was exactly
the same as another,
which you can't
say about American
playgrounds unfortunately.
But some of the typical
elements they have are towers.
And they're much
taller than ours.
And they have different
ways of getting
to those towers that are
sometimes a little dangerous.
Here's an example.
That's my daughter up there.
And you can see from the
height that it's at least twice
as tall as she is.
And she's on a log with
just a rope to hang on.
So there's a lot of
chance to fall there.
So she's learning right there
how to manage some risk.
And not only are they more
dangerous or more risky.
They're more fun.
I mean, what's more
fun, this or this?
Now, this one's
actually in Bavaria.
A friend sent it to me.
And that kid is up kind of high.
This is more of a
side view of it.
These climbing rope
triangles are fairly common.
And if you see at
the end, that tail--
this whole thing is
sort of like a snake.
That tail is a slide.
So the reward for
climbing up there
is you get to go down that
really fun slide, which
might be a little scary.
Now, I was lucky enough
that, in our neighborhood,
we had something
called [GERMAN]..
And that's the
[GERMAN] right there.
Now, this dragon has
since been torn down.
And then they built another one.
But it's not only high.
It has a scary look to it.
It's got these big red teeth.
And the kids can actually
climb up into those teeth.
They can also hang out in
this gullet right here.
And they're two enormous slides
that go down the side-- metal,
so they're fast.
My daughter was
terrified of this thing.
She would not go near it.
Of course, she was really small.
That was her when we
first arrived in Berlin.
And this is the area in
front of the dragon, which
has some swings and some other
things that you can climb.
And for years, she would only
play around with the dragon.
The most she would do with
it would be go up the back
and down again, and up and down.
And that was it.
So flash forward two years,
I've got a new baby boy now.
And I'm watching him a lot
more than I'm watching her.
And I hear, mama, mama, mama.
And I'm like, ugh,
she's hurt herself.
I wasn't watching her.
Oh, my gosh.
But then I look up,
and she's in the teeth.
And then she comes
down the slide.
And when she stands on
it, you can just see it.
She had conquered her fear.
I didn't make her do it.
She did it all by herself.
And I think that's a really
important step for a child
to take, even when they're
five, is to face something
that they're afraid of and
to overcome it themselves,
and in their own way.
I mean, she was working
up to that point,
I think, for a long time.
And I'm a little afraid
that American kids don't
get a chance to conquer a
dragon very much anymore,
at least outside
of a video game.
This picture was taken actually
several years after that,
because you see there's
another little face up there.
And that's her brother.
So I guess if you have
a brave older sister,
you get pushed to do
things a little bit faster.
But another really important way
that Germans prepare their kids
is through using dangerous
implements that we normally
don't.
And there's none that is more
stark of an example than fire.
What are we taught about
fire when we're kids?
Don't play with it.
Don't play with matches.
If you ever seen a
lighter, go tell an adult.
That's not for kids.
That's not the prevailing
wisdom in Germany.
In fact, my daughter came
home from first grade one day,
and she said, mom, I would
like to light some candles.
Because she had learned how
to light matches in school.
And that was quite
shocking for me.
But she had the note
from her teacher.
And the idea behind
this is that Germans
think it's safer
to teach a kid how
to use something
that's potentially
dangerous than to prohibit it.
Because when you
prohibit, there's
a great amount of children,
especially when it
comes to fire, who
will try it in secret.
And of course, in secret is
dangerous because it's secret.
And because they have
no capability at it.
You actually have to
know how to hold a match.
A lot of young kids
will hold it like this.
And the fire burns
their fingers.
And then they drop it.
And then maybe something
catches on fire, right?
And their first thought,
if it's prohibited,
is, I'm going to get in trouble.
And then they run, or they hide.
And that's how a lot of
child-started fires happen.
Now, there is a
man in [INAUDIBLE]
who is a pioneer in this area.
And he teaches kids who
are even younger than seven
how to light
matches and candles.
But not only how to light
matches and candles,
but how to make bonfires.
Now, [INAUDIBLE],, he's kind
of an interesting character.
Because he used to
be a fire artist.
And he once burned the
Berlin Wall in the 1980s.
He has since got a second career
as a fire safety instructor.
And his idea of fire safety
is to teach very young kids,
ages 4, 5, and 6--
this is at a [GERMAN],,
which is like a daycare center--
how to deal with fire.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [SPEAKING GERMAN]
[END PLAYBACK]
SARA ZASKE: What I love
about this video so much is,
not only do you see these
small kids making fire,
but you see them sawing
things using an ax,
cutting food, and cooking it.
And I think it really
challenges our notion
that kids are
incapable and that they
need everything done for them.
With a little instruction,
they seem to manage quite well.
Now, these kind of workshops
are everywhere in Germany.
They're more common in
Berlin and Brandenburg.
But before you think [INAUDIBLE]
is a complete crazy man,
he has the backing of
insurance agencies,
child safety organizations,
and the Berlin [GERMAN],,
the city fire department.
And when I think back to
when I saw a firefighter come
to my elementary
school, they stood
at the front of the classroom.
And they told me not
to play with matches
and how to stop, drop, and
roll, which are all good things.
But never did I make
a fire with a fireman,
which might be
quite an experience.
So the German way
of dealing with fire
is almost the complete
opposite of ours.
However, I have
found no evidence
that child-started fires are of
any greater number in Germany
than they are here where we
have a lot of prohibition.
So that begs the question
then, if we're prohibiting it
and it's not working,
then why are we doing it?
And what is being lost
through that prohibition?
And I think, if you saw
those kids in that video,
they were incredibly engaged.
Kids are very
fascinated with fire.
And some people even
think we're evolutionary
wired to be fascinated
by fire because we used
to depend upon it for so long.
But this is also an opportunity
for learning, really intense
learning for them.
And that's another subject that
we are very concerned about,
right?
We all want to know what
makes children succeed.
Out here in the US,
we have pushed down
a lot of conceptual
learning into kindergarten
and to preschool.
And we do worksheets and
flash cards with kids.
In fact, Americans are
famous for trying to push
learning earlier and earlier.
The psychologist
Jean Piaget once
called it the "American
question" back in the 1970s.
And that question was,
can we do it faster?
How can we do it earlier?
And he didn't answer
that question, why do you
want to do that earlier?
And I have to say,
I'm guilty of it.
Because back in the US
before we left Germany,
I had this brilliant
little daughter
who could speak at
a really early age.
And I thought, she's a genius.
I got to help her.
And I started to teach
her how to spell.
I taught her to spell her
name while we were swinging.
And I would swing
her back and forth.
And she'd say,
S-O-P-H-I-A, Sophia.
And I was like,
oh, that's great.
I'll try something else.
OK, Sophia, let's spell mommy.
And she would say,
S-O-P-H-I-A, mommy!
So we may be able
to get young kids
to repeat back to us a lot of
things, including math facts.
And you may even be able
to get them to read,
which, by the way, has
very little evidence
that it gives them an
advantage later on.
In fact, there was a study that
compared early readers of four
or five with later
readers of more
the traditional seven or eight.
By the time both
sets got to be 11,
the late readers had caught up.
So again, if it doesn't
give them an advantage,
why are we doing it?
And more importantly,
what are they
missing while we are trying
to cram reading and math
at an early, early age?
And I would argue that
they're missing play.
And play is so essential.
All mammals do it, including us.
And it's kind of the
primary way that we learn.
In kindergarten, which
was invented in Germany,
at least there,
Frederick [INAUDIBLE]
had the idea that child
learning would take place
in a kind of Eden.
Thus, the "garten"
in kindergarten.
And that play was essential.
And they've had some
changes in kindergarten.
But they are back to that model.
And all they do in preschool
and kindergarten is play.
And when the ambitious
American in me
got nervous about that,
they would tell me,
really, they are learning.
They're learning social skills.
They're learning how to be
creative, how to be leaders,
how to have self-control.
And a lot of the
kindergartens there
practice what's
called the [GERMAN]
or what used to be known here
as the observational approach.
The teachers would step
back and watch what
was going on with the kids.
And this is one example.
Every year in the
"garten" at our [GERMAN],,
they would have a lot
of chestnuts come down
from the trees.
And the kids love them.
They would cram their
pockets full of them,
take them home, take
them in the inside rooms.
Rather than fight
it, they said, go.
Get all of them that you can.
And they bring them
in to play with them.
Now, I'm sure there's some
math skills going on here.
But they're not
very [? formal. ?]
The other kinds of
things that they would do
is they would do
projects with the kids,
but only projects that
kids chose themselves.
So they would have a little
meeting, and they'd say, OK,
what should our next project be?
And kids would throw out
ideas, and they vote on them.
How democratic, right?
And then they have
the kids throw out
all the questions they have
about that particular idea.
For instance, they did
a body project one year.
And so kids wanted to
know, how do the eyes see?
How do the ears hear?
The heart beats?
What's my skeleton look like?
And so after that, for
over a period of weeks,
they would investigate it.
They'd get books.
They'd watch videos.
They'd bring in an expert like
a doctor or go on a field trip
to a museum.
And through that
process, they're
learning how to engage
their curiosity.
And they're really
learning how to learn.
And this whole emphasis on
play and self-directed learning
goes on through
elementary school,
so until third or fourth grade.
And if that worries
you, consider
that German teenagers,
by the time they're 15,
do much better on the
International PISA Test
than Americans.
That's math,
science, and reading.
So maybe our
emphasis on academics
so early might be misplaced
and that maybe the kids
need more of a foundation
of this kind of exploration.
Oh, the last method
of preparation,
I just wanted to touch on
briefly, is information.
Germans are much more
open with difficult topics
with their kids than we are.
And these are things like sex,
religion, death, all of which
my daughter had
projects on in school
by the time of third grade.
And of course, for Germany,
the darker parts of history
is a huge topic.
But just to give you one example
for sex education, in Germany,
it's mandatory.
You cannot opt your child
out of it for any reason,
not even religion.
Because they believe
the kids have a right
to know how their
body works, which
I don't know how you take that.
But when I looked at the
statistics, in the end,
teenagers in Germany
are no more sexually
active than American teenagers.
In fact, the statistics
are almost identical.
The big difference, however,
are in other very important
statistics.
Germans have a much lower
rate of teen pregnancy,
a much lower rate
of teen abortion,
and a much lower rate
of HIV incidence.
So no matter what my morality
is around sex and my kids
having it at a certain point,
that information is powerful.
And it has the power to help
them protect themselves.
So then the big question.
How do we do any of this here?
We have a very different
culture, right?
And I have to admit there
are some things that
happen in German society
that are society-based.
And making changes in our school
system or our preschool system
or even getting a more exciting
playground down the street
would take a lot of effort
by a group of people.
But there are several
things that we can
do as parents and as citizens.
And one of the first ones
is what we talked about
in the beginning--
letting your kids learn to
navigate their own world.
A child of seven,
eight, or nine is
very capable of
taking themselves
to a place, especially
one that they
go to often, like a
friend's house, the school,
or the playground.
And if it makes you nervous,
try it out the German way.
Go with them a lot of times.
Teach them traffic.
Talk to them about strangers
possibly approaching them.
Though you should emphasize
it doesn't happen very often.
And if it still makes you
nervous, find them a buddy.
Because two kids
walking down the street
feels a lot safer than one.
And it also helps if there are
siblings involved, I think.
Another thing that
we can do as parents
is to make time in every
day that the kids get
to decide what to do with it.
And because we have a longer
school day now and homework
and then extracurricular
activities,
some kids can go
from first thing
in the morning to
the evening never
being able to decide
what they want to do.
So for us, when I do
this with my kids,
it usually means playing.
And it's very
important for them,
I think, to play every day
as it is to get outside,
which is also a German value.
And that's not something
that's too hard to do either,
though it does require
a push a little bit.
And another idea is
to give them some life
tasks, even at a young age.
My daughter does her
own laundry, which
means I put a bin in her room.
She fills it.
When it's full, she does the
laundry and has clean clothes.
I really like this
one because it
has very natural consequences.
I don't have to nag.
When she doesn't do her laundry,
she doesn't have clean clothes.
And for a while,
she didn't care.
But now, she
really, really does.
And it gets done.
And other things like
this are waking yourself
up in the morning.
Cooking also has very
natural consequences.
And they tend to be
very engaged, especially
if you couch it as teaching you
how to take care of yourself.
It's not necessarily a chore.
It's a bit of a step
towards independence.
And if we teach our kids these
smaller things now at this age,
they get to have a growing
sense of capability.
And as they get older, we
can give them more and more
responsibility so that
it's not such a shock
when they become 18.
I don't know about you,
but I did know some people
in college who had
never done laundry, who
had never made a pot of rice.
And they're missing out a lot.
They have to catch
up really fast.
And last, but not
least, is the idea
I brought up here about being
more open with your kids
about difficult topics.
They can handle it.
And I want to tell
you a short story
about World War II in Germany.
You can't avoid the topic of
World War II in the Holocaust
if you live in Berlin especially
because it's everywhere.
Your kids are going to ask you.
They'll see these
little gold [GERMAN]
in the street that memorialize
people who are taken off
to die in concentration camps.
And whenever I ask my
German friends, the adults,
about World War II,
they would tell me,
I cannot remember a time when I
didn't know what my country had
done.
And that really
affected me because,
if they couldn't remember
when they didn't know--
they must have been five maybe,
six when they learned about one
of the biggest crimes
in modern history
that their own culture had done.
That's a really heavy issue.
And those kids were about
as old as those kids
you saw making the
fire and using the ax.
So I think our kids are
more capable than we realize
or that we give them credit for.
They're more capable of
handling physical freedom
and handling tough,
intellectual,
and emotional subjects.
And that's the idea I'd like to
end the presentation with here.
I think, if we as parents
can get a handle on our fears
like the Germans do
and step back and give
our kids the space
they need, then
they can grow up
to be independent,
self-reliant adults.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
SARA ZASKE: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
any advice for parents
who would like to give
their kids more freedom
but are concerned about
things like your kids
getting taken by CPS as happened
to that couple in Maryland?
SARA ZASKE: Right.
Absolutely.
I mean, we do have that problem.
Germans have a sense of
community in the sense
that, if their kids
gets in trouble
that people will help them.
And here we've come
to a part of society
where people tend to
call the police on you.
The best advice
I can give you is
to try to know your community
and talk to your community.
That means talking
to your neighbors
and the fellow parents.
And let them know
what you're doing.
My kid really would like
to try walking to school.
I'm going to let
them do it tomorrow.
And you can get them in on it.
If they're a busybody, be like,
could you look out your window,
make sure they're OK?
I think if we start
to draw people in
to be proactively helpful
instead of negative,
then perhaps we can
start to build that here.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SARA ZASKE: Your welcome.
AUDIENCE: How did
you get your daughter
to start caring about not
wearing dirty clothes?
SARA ZASKE: It was
actually pretty natural.
There was a little
bit of rebellion.
I don't care, for a bit.
And then her favorite
shirt wasn't washed.
And it just kind of happened.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I've
actually been thinking
about a lot of these
issues for a long time.
I have a 3-and-1/2-year-old and
I've been trying to introduce
her to things that I,
as an overprotected kid,
wasn't able to do until much
later but I feel like she can.
What I've been
trying to figure out
is kind of at what
ages to do what things.
And it feels like a
lot of the resources,
especially on the
internet-- ugh--
in America for
determining when is
a reasonable safe time where,
like you said, five or six
for fire.
Can you recommend any
resources for figuring out
how much earlier than the
American very conservative
norms different
things could be moved?
SARA ZASKE: Well, I'm
really reluctant to say
that any specific age is
good for a specific task.
It's really important to see
when your kid is ready for it.
And often, they'll tell you.
You can suggest some things, and
they'll be like, ugh, no way.
And I don't recommend forcing
a kid who's reluctant.
If you wanted to start with
cutting up potatoes together
and they don't want to touch
the knife, I would wait.
They'll come back.
And I'll tell you a short story
about my son in the first time
he wanted to walk to school.
He was 6, and we
were in America.
And he actually
wanted to walk home.
I had driven that day.
And he had no interest
in getting in the car.
And that first time
he ran the whole way.
And he was scared.
He didn't really tell me he
was scared, but I kind of knew.
And then he didn't ask again
for two or three weeks.
Then when he did
it the second time,
that's when it clicked for him.
And today, he
walks all the time.
So I would think suggesting
some things your kids
and see if they're into it.
And then if they
go for it, yeah.
But if they don't, back off.
Walking to school, the Germans
do it at about seven and eight.
The Fins do it at four and five.
So it's kind of a
cultural thing as well.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
thoughts, observations of how
Germans teach responsibility?
So for example, you give an
example of kindergarten--
just play all day.
But do they get taught
like cleaning up.
It's not a very
natural consequence,
like dirty clothes.
So just wondering what your
thoughts are and observations--
SARA ZASKE: Sure.
AUDIENCE: If there's
any differences.
SARA ZASKE: It was
fairly freeform.
The kindergarten we went
to had very few rules
that the kids didn't
make themselves.
So they actually would
sit the kids around
and go, what should be the
rules for our [GERMAN]..
And one kid will say, don't
climb on the furniture.
And she'd say, why
don't you do that?
She's like, I don't want
your dirty feet on it.
Or don't hit other kids.
Well, that's a
really natural one.
Why?
Because it hurts.
The second answer is
always the most powerful.
Other kids won't want
to play with you.
So they learn some
responsibility
just through the
interaction with each other.
Now, if you're thinking
our parental interactions
with them, all
this responsibility
is rescindable, this freedom.
So if they are being allowed
to walk to school and instead
on the way home they
stop at a friend's house,
then you say, OK, then
maybe we need to take
a break from it for a while.
And I think kids,
in that sense, they
get a little bit of freedom and
then the accountability for it.
So that when they're
older, they're
not just going out
there and going crazy.
AUDIENCE: The most amount of
[INAUDIBLE] to give my kid
is for food.
Because if I let him
pick what he needs,
like if I have grains,
vegetables, and fruit,
[INAUDIBLE] I'm done.
Later in the evening, he'll
ask for something else.
So I don't know how to manage
that, teaching him such control
and responsibility [INAUDIBLE].
SARA ZASKE: Food is a hard one.
But I've heard that--
if you think about the
food you hate most in life.
For me, I'm really not a
big fan of Brussels sprouts.
Not for any particular
reason, but because I remember
being forced to eat them.
And they have that
connotation on it forever.
So I would urge you not to
force them to eat anything.
I'm always a big fan
of continuing to offer.
You only put out on the table
what you want them to eat.
But then he gets to
choose from that.
And of course, the sweets
are only for treats and not
for all the time.
The Germans do this a little
bit just through the way
they do school lunches.
Nobody brings their own lunch.
So they have two choices
usually, a vegetarian
and a non-vegetarian.
And if you don't like
it, you go hungry.
So kids tend to eat
if they're hungry.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for the talk.
This is actually really nice.
My question is-- so if you
look at culture around here
in the US.
So for example, there was
a movie [INAUDIBLE] called
"Kidnap" with Halle Berry.
SARA ZASKE: Ugh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: It was
on accord of her
taking her eyes off
her kid for a second
and the kid got kidnapped.
And then [INAUDIBLE]
and all that stuff.
My question is-- so if
I see a movie like that,
I'm less reluctant to
let my kid walk to school
or lay on the playground
unsupervised for a second.
So how do you reconcile with
an environment like that?
Because I'm assuming,
like in Germany,
they have a lot more control
over their media, or at least
that's the perception
that I have being here
that they can prevent movies
like this from coming out.
Saying, hey, don't
show things like this.
[INAUDIBLE] kids walk
to school on their own.
So how do we reconcile this?
Thank you.
SARA ZASKE: It is a
different media environment.
I don't know that they
control it so much.
But there would not be as much
interest in that kind of movie.
We like to scare
ourselves a lot here.
What I really wish would
happen in our media
is that, whenever
they tell us one
of the real stories of
a kid being kidnapped
that they put it in context.
And as a formal
journalist, I wish
we could require this because
you're always supposed
to put things in context.
A little more than
100 kids get kidnapped
by strangers every year.
Absolutely every
story is horrific.
It's every parent's nightmare.
But we have 77 million
kids in this country.
Something happening to 100
kids is an aberration, not
a thing that happens every day.
And if we knew that, if we
keep thinking about that,
I think we might
change our behavior.
And one other short
story if I may.
The far more common scenario
of a kid being sexually abused
is by someone they know.
And it's usually a man.
And that man wants to have a
relationship with your child.
Now, the child that has
been very constrained
and told to obey adults and
respect their elders all
the time is much easier
prey to a person like that
than a kid who's been
raised to be independent,
is able to say no to adults.
So there's a really
strong argument
right there for making
your kid more independent
actually protects them.
AUDIENCE: OK, I come from a
slightly different perspective.
[GERMAN] So as you
see, I'm from Germany.
And when we moved
here, the school system
here does not really like if
your kids have these values
that you propagate here.
So for your own
children and in general,
how do you propose
that the school
system and this
kind of education
really works together?
Because for our kids,
it's very interesting.
So for example, things like
the Pledge of Allegiance
in elementary school.
This was pretty scary
from my perspective.
But all this value on secondary
virtues like being on time,
having all your work
done and, well, all
this control that you mentioned
that does not really go well
with this style of education.
SARA ZASKE: I've handled it
a couple of different ways.
I've had teachers who are
receptive to it and schools
that are.
I tell them my kids
are allowed to go home.
Sometimes I have
to write a note,
because we're a very
litigious culture, saying
that they have my permission
to do these things.
And sometimes I get a
little passive aggressive.
I have a teacher--
kids do not need to do
homework in elementary school.
I'll say that there are
no grades, especially
until third grade.
And there's no proof
that doing homework
helps in elementary school.
And I have had arguments
with teachers about this.
And other times, I've just
said to my son, don't do it.
You don't have to
do the homework.
And if you want to
do it and you want
to bring me the
little piece of paper
that I'm supposed
to sign, which is
a really interesting transfer
of responsibility, you can.
And the moment he does
that, he'll probably
have passed some bar.
But I don't let them
make me control him.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: OK.
SARA ZASKE: Yeah.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
theories on how American
culture developed this way?
SARA ZASKE: Yeah.
Unfortunately, I
only have theories.
A lot of it is the media
and those scary stories
and scary movies.
I mean, we have a show.
I think it's called
"Law and Order--
Special Victims Unit"
where every week a child
is in some horrific situation.
And it gives the impression
that this happens often.
I also think that we have
a very competitive culture
and always have.
So we are so worried
about our kids' success
that we think we need to start
them on that treadmill early.
And it's actually had
some very bad results.
Because if you're
a kid and you're
working really hard in
kindergarten and in first grade
so that you can work really
hard in middle school
and high school so you can
get into a good college
and worked really hard to get a
good job so you can work really
hard, that can be
very depressing and
anxiety-producing.
Where is the moment
for enjoyment
and the meaning of life really?
Is it just to constantly compete
and be the best and make money?
Or is there something else
there that's of value?
And I think if we
change our view on that
and how we communicate
with our kids,
it could help them out a lot.
OK, should we break
at this point?
SPEAKER 1: Any more questions?
AUDIENCE: What's in the book?
SARA ZASKE: What's in the book?
Some of those
stories I told here.
It's a research
memoir, so it's partly
my stories and experiences.
And it's partly I talked
to a lot of experts
and looked at studies as well.
And I would say
it's part manifesto
because I'm trying to make an
argument that we should give
our kids more independence.
SPEAKER 1: Thanks
for coming everybody.
[APPLAUSE]